bonsoir à tous le vote et Claude il est
l'heure de passer au dépouillement
musique
pour
[Musique]
j'ai faim vite ah ça c'est Patrick
celui-ci
est adopté clairement pour l'adoption
278 la majorité requise n'étant pas
atteinte la motion de censure n'est pas
adoptée
déjà ses opposants de la nupesse
affichent leur intention avec ses
pancartes RIP référendum d'initiatives
partagées manière de dire que faute de
motion de censure ils utiliseront tous
les recours pour bloquer la réforme à
15h vous pourrez suivre notre édition
spéciale consacrée aux motions de
censure déposées à l'Assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui en France des millions de
personnes âgées sont restées en état de
choc des hommes et des femmes abasourdi
à l'annonce de cette catastrophe qui a
chamboulé leur quotidien jamais ils ne
seront à combien a été estimé le
guéridon de Jean-Louis aujourd'hui à
cause d'Elizabeth borne France de a des
programmes et à faire conclue chienne de
vie
49,3.000 abonnés hier enfin de journée
le compte Instagram d'Élisabeth borne
affiché ce nombre symbolique de
followers il ne s'agit pas d'une
coïncidence mais d'une blague d'un
internaute qui a déboursé quelques euros
pour acheter des abonnés à la première
ministre la nouvelle se répand et
beaucoup immortalise le canular une
bonne idée car dans la soirée l'équipe
de communication d'Elisabeth borne
supprime ses nouveaux followers pour
effacer la référence à l'article 49-3 le
49-3 c'est qu'une goutte c'est le goutte
qui fait déborder le vase quelque part
tu as qu'à demander une écoute pas et
les gens les gens montrent les gens
montent et là mon gars tu vas
personnaliser cette colère et moi je te
le dis la violence c'est pas la solution
mais la violence c'est l'outil que les
gens il leur reste il leur reste que cet
outil là tu votes tu votes pour des mecs
pendant un intervie de ta gueule qui
vont demander un autoroute à Macron pour
voter une noix dégueulasse c'est que des
trucs comme ça aujourd'hui les gens ils
se disent mais qu'est-ce qu'il nous
reste Emmanuel Macron il avait dit c'est
moi ou le chaos et actuellement on a
Emmanuel Macron et le chaos quelle chute
si vous me permettez de finir
je vais finir
non pas après cette logorrhée de
répondre au chantage et je m'excuserai
pas de
problème je vous dis parce que
er
la violence vous l'avez introduite dans
l'hémicycle dans vos propos alors c'est
bien beau maintenant d'aller faire la
rue et de vouloir tout casser quand on a
quand on a eu l'occasion de voter les
trois quarts ils avaient voté François
Hollande à l'époque ils ont vu ce que ça
a donné ils nous ont mis Macron il nous
remettent Macron et il s'étonne de la
merde dans laquelle on est alors que le
mec au final que je l'aime ou que je
l'aime pas il a été transparent il peut
pas dire que cette mesure il allait pas
la passer mais après
quand quelqu'un a pas de poursuite ça
veut dire qu'elle était en garde à vue
de manière arbitraire toutes ces
organisations internationales vous le
disent parce que je sais avez-vous oui
madame condamné la police maintenant
après ne pas avoir condamné les
violences les menaces malheureusement
vous ne savez vous nous avez habitués en
gros j'aime la France c'est compliqué
dès que tu dis je suis paysan c'est
compliqué non oui le faitait
qu'effectivement j'avais j'avais de la
famille dans mes dents mais c'est vrai
il a fallu dans le Médoc qui est dans le
Béarn je viens de là j'ai un nez à la
Henri IV je suppose que c'est c'est lié
mais mais le fait que oui je peux pas
faire autrement je je ne sais plus
comment le dire en fait je ne sais plus
comment le dire sans que ça s'énerve
madame pour des salariés
quand vous aurez fini de parler les uns
sur les autres en hurlant sans que
personne ne comprennent rien à ce qui se
passe sans respecter qui que ce soit je
dis ça pour vous deux pardonnez-moi vous
renvoie
parce qu'ils vont bosser 2 ans de plus
ça me je crois que ça me désespère un
peu le Bureau international du Travail
dit que la moyenne
de temps travaillé par semaine dans le
monde c'est 60 heures ouais tu as 35 on
est très très loin par exemple que ah
oui mais les éboueurs c'est terrible
parce que ils partent à 57 ans au
chômage à la retraite ils vont partir à
59 ans mais personne n'est obligé d'être
éboueur toute sa vie vous voyez ce
temps-là il y a 10 minutes encore il y
avait un camion de poubelle de la ville
de Paris avec 6 ou 7 agents qui étaient
en train de d'entamer les poubelles qui
étaient sur le piéton et ils ont dû
s'arrêter parce que le camion était
plein et ça évidemment c'est une donnée
importante du problème parce qu'il y a
tellement de poubelles qui se sont
accumulées en 15 jours que ils ne
peuvent même pas nettoyer toute la rue
au bout de quelques centaines de mètres
il faut aller vider le camion et ça
énormément ça prend du temps il faudrait
au moins 3 jours de ramassage à plein
régime pour évacuer les 9000 tonnes de
poubelles encore dans Paris regardez les
invités en plateau ont le droit grand
maximum à une petite fenêtre en bas de
l'écran les images qui font peur avant
tout et tant pis s'ils ne se passe pas
grand chose 90% du temps
c'est vrai que la journée quelque chose
de très calme on voit ses policiers qui
sont statique
qu'est-ce qui se passe
qu'est-ce qui se passe oh merde
un rap ils ont attrapé un rat
merde
[Applaudissements]
du côté de cnews les invités en plateau
avaient droit à un sixième de l'écran et
on a adoré comment le bandeau s'est
emballé en quelques minutes de faut-il
craindre une nouvelle soirée de violence
puis la France au bord de l'implosion on
était très vite arrivés à doit-on
craindre le retour de communisme où sont
les Français issus de l'immigration
depuis deux mois
sur cette réforme ils sont nulle part
nulle part j'ai l'impression que de voir
de manifestations pardonnez-moi j'ai un
prêt alors je prends toujours des
précautions orateurs quand je dis ça
j'ai l'impression que c'est la France
blanche qui qui la France contre les la
France où est où sont les français où
sont les banlieues où sont les
représentants
ah bah oui j'ai compris j'ai compris oui
évidemment vive la France vive la
république mais vive la langue française
puisque c'est la Semaine de la
francophonie et à chaque fois je dis
j'aime la France ou c'est récupérer par
un parti politique ou tes suspects ou
alors faut avoir un maillot de foot pour
le dire en fait quand tu dis j'aime la
France et j'ai un maillot de foot il y a
aucun problème les drapeaux se dressent
dès que tu sors du stade il y a plus de
drapeau et était suspect et donc bon ça
va être la folie gros match gros
supportatrice là moi